l'association Les Amis du Vieux
Saint-Germain fête ses 100 ans cette
année à la pour but de valoriser le
patrimoine historique de la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et pour en parler
avec nous ce soir son secrétaire général
Jean-Claude Pelletier alors Jean-Claude
Pelletier vous nous l'avez un petit peu
rappelé en début d'émission mais quelle
est l'histoire en fait de cette
association parce qu'elle a été créée en
1923 est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler son histoire alors c'est un
nommé Louis forest qui était un élu qui
a décidé en 1922 donc de lancer une
association dont la qui a été créé en
mars 1923 donc et qui a réuni beaucoup
de personnalités à l'époque
qui était en général des élus locaux
mais il y avait par exemple ne faisait
partie de l'association
membre du comité le peintre Maurice
Denis qui est d'ailleurs son musée du
prieuré
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye il y avait
Anatole France par exemple
donc des des hautes personnalités et qui
se sont lancés dans des dans deux
directions la première c'est vraiment
des études je dirais presque
d'archéologie
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye et dans les
environs et ils ont découvert un certain
nombre de choses et puis également de la
diffusion par des conférences par des
visites et
ils ont eu un succès inespéré puisqu'ils
sont arrivés très vite à 400 adhérents
et
ceci a très bien marché jusqu'à la mort
de Louis forest malheureusement qui est
décédé assez rapidement et là ça a
commencé un peu à baisser il y a eu de
moins en moins de visites et beaucoup
moins d'adhérents et puis la guerre est
intervenue s'il y a eu du mal à
reprendre après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et ce n'est que dans les années
60 que ça reprit avec en particulier la
participation de l'association à toute
une un projet
urbain la municipalité les a fait appel
à l'association pour essayer de d'aider
à classer des bâtiments et éviter qu'ils
deviennent l'objet de spéculation
immobilière
c'est toujours un peu le problème c'est
le moment on est en train de glorieuses
c'est le moment où il y avait beaucoup
de construction donc il y a eu ils ont
fait un gros travail à cette époque mais
la contrepartie c'est qu'il y avait
moins d'adhérents puisque c'était
vraiment des spécialistes qui épuisent
l'association avec plus d'adhérents
il y a eu des nouveaux présidents des
nouveaux présidents qui étaient
quelqu'un qui sortait du conseil
municipal qui et qui a dit il faut
relancer et qui a cherché à faire
plus moins peut-être de scientifiques et
plus de
je dirais de diffusion et alors on a eu
vulgarisation et participation aussi que
les gens participent à part le biais de
visite par de conférence
de voyage même donc des petit à petit
c'est remonté et on est maintenant on
n'a pas tout à fait rattrapé 1923 mais
nous sommes à 350 adhérents donc c'est
quelque chose qui est pas mal et nous
faisons donc tout un panel de
d'activités alors justement parlez-en
quels sont les activités un peu
marquantes de cette association
et un colloque chaque année bon un coloc
important qui fait venir des
intervenants renommés et qui ont un
sujet
qui peut être très variable mais
toujours lié à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
alors cette année sera sur quoi alors
cette année ça va être les
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les 100 ans d'une
société savante et on fait intervenir
les sociétés savantes de la région
donc qui aura lieu au mois de mars c'est
normal s'entend après donc
ça fait partie de la fête pour pour
célébrer vos 100 ans ce colloque où
c'est à Paris
toute l'année qui est le centenaire et
donc on a des conférences dont une patte
mais la majeure partie sont consacrés
aux années 20 alors pas uniquement à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye nous avons eu
je dirais la création enfin
le rail à Saint-Germain-en-Laye gare
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la ligne Paris
saint-germain-en-layette est la première
voie ferrée française alors là on n'est
pas dans le centenaire là on est presque
à 200 ans
mais ensuite nous avons alors des
conférences qui
est présente la France
dans les années 20
avec un petit accent sur l'art quand
même l'art et la musique parce que c'est
très très important et puis nous avons
une conférence très simple très
importante c'est le centenaire du Bol
d'Or il se trouve que le premier vol
d'or a eu à Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc
il y aura une conférence au mois de juin
sur le Bol d'Or les 100 ans du Bol d'Or
et puis nous
nous avons en plus un certain nombre de
concerts auxquels nous emmenons nos
adhérents la Philharmonie
nous avons des visites et nous terminons
l'année par un grand concert
qui touche tout Saint-Germain-en-Laye
c'est-à-dire que ce sont les Amis du
Vieux Saint-Germain qui organise le
concert
ce concert il y a un cœur qui est le
cœur Saint Germain donc le cœur de la
paroi Saint-Germain à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et l'orchestre et
l'orchestre de Saint-Germain qui est
récent qui a été créé il y a deux ou
trois ans et qui est très très bon
moitié professionnel moitié amateur donc
ceci mais en plus nous on est associé à
l'Université Libre de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la municipalité
nous soutient et tout ceci a lieu au
Théâtre Alexandre Dumas de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc voyez on est
vraiment complètement les gars voilà et
donc voilà si vous voulez en gros les
activités de cette année qui sont liées
au centenaire sinon nous avons
chaque année de voyage
un voyage en France et un voyage à
l'étranger et alors cette année je crois
qu'il y en a un en Haute-Marne et du
coup à l'étranger ce sera en Italie on a
un peu pris par le temps est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler juste rapidement
alors pour la Haute-Marne si vous voulez
quand on parle de la Haute-Marne les
gens en général nous dit tiens et
pourtant il y a des choses
extraordinaires en Haute-Marne je dirais
ne serait-ce que colomber les deux
églises qui est quand même un lieu
symbolique mais il y a la ville de
Londres par exemple et puis
si vous voulez un certain nombre à
Chaumont il y a des choses nos jantes
etc enfin vous avez
des lieux qui sont extrêmement
intéressants et alors l'Italie vous
allez où l'Italie ce sera Raven
puis les villas palladiennes avec un
petit passage quand même à Padoue il y a
une chapelle absolument magnifique avec
des fresques du gel auto donc si vous
voulez tout ceci prévu en septembre non
que l'an prochain on est déjà sur la
préparation des voyages de l'an prochain
parce que c'est évident qu'on prend un
peu d'avance merci beaucoup Jean-Claude
Pelletier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation du coup je le rappelle vous
êtes le secrétaire général de
l'association Les Amis de Saint-Germain
je vous souhaite un vieux Saint-Germain
alors faut faire attention on nous
appelle les vieux singes
on va éviter en tout cas je vous
souhaite un joyeux centenaire du coup
merci beaucoup